si le niveau global de la circulation du
virus est aujourd'hui comparable à celui
du début de l'automne dernier des
signaux d'alert se font jour dans
certains territoires et je tenais à
m'exprimer sur ce point en occitanie un
nouvel aquitaine nous constatons des
hausses parfois sensible de la
circulation du virus sur cette région
la nouvelle aquitaine le taux de
reproduction du virus le fameux air est
repassé au-dessus de 1 ce qui signifie
que l'épidémie il gagne de nouveau du
terrain
cette évolution défavorable est
particulièrement marquée dans le
département des pyrénées atlantiques où
l'incidence a progressé de près de 80%
sur une semaine elle l'est dans une
moindre mesure en charente-maritime dans
le lot et garonne en charente dans les
landes et en gironde
que les choses soient claires le niveau
de circulation du virus reste modéré le
taux d'incidence par exemple dans le
département des pyrénées atlantiques que
j'évoquais il y a un instant et 235 ceux
qui restent modérées mais c'est la
dynamique de progression qui constitue
un signal d'arrêt train de finale d'
alerte et qui doit à mener chacune et
chacun évidemment à la plus grande
vigilance